umso mehr freut es mich dass Sie mich heute
Abend hier mit warmem Applaus begrüßt haben
obwohl es für sie vielleicht auch verwirrend
war Schweizerin macht politisches Kabarett was
soll das die Frau kann in ihrer Heimat ja erst
seit 1991 wählen gehen wie will die da jetzt
schon lustig sein aber genau das sage ich ja die
Welt ist durcheinander Schweizerinnen machen in
Deutschland politisches Kabarett Bayern wählen
grüne und Engländer schreiben jetzt Kochbücher
an was sollst du da noch glauben
oder an was sind wir noch bereit
zu glauben heute war die Fakten ja immer
mehr denn Meinungen angepasst werden oder
warum sonst gibt's massiv mehr Eltern von
hochbegabten Kindern also hochbegabte Kinder
oder all die alten Männer die immer noch denken
eine junge Freundin lässt sie jünger erscheinen
nein tut's nicht aber hey lassen Sie sich Ihre
Meinung nicht von Fakten kaputt machen wir sind
ja bereits das zu glauben was wir glauben wollen
und ich habe ihn dazu ein Bild mitgebracht aus
Italien ein italienischer Zoo wollte seinen
Publikum Pandabären zeigen das Problem war
die hatten keine Pandabären also was haben
sie gemacht sie haben einfach Hunde angemalt
und die Leute haben es geglaubt als das
aufflug war das ein Riesenskandal und
was jetzt jemand im Publikum gedacht hat
typisch italienisch dann haben sie recht
ich ganz beurteilen ich bin selber zur Hälfte
Italienerin mein Vater ist in den 70er Jahren
aus der Schweiz also Italien in die Schweiz
eingewandert und ja sie haben Recht lassen
Sie sich von italienisch auch kein Pandabär
und gar nicht wenn der aussieht wie ein Hund
wir müssen uns heute genau überlegen wir müssen
genau hinschauen und uns immer fragen kann das
wirklich sein das wichtig gerade heute aber die
Welt immer mehr immun wird gegen Fakten es gibt
mittlerweile so viele Idioten da draußen die
die Fakten Leuten zum Beispiel all die Spinner
die immer noch behaupten die Mondlandung
damals die sei in Arizona inszeniert gewesen
das war in Nevada
aber Kabarett klärts ja auf und deshalb habe
ich Ihnen heute ein paar historische Fakten
mitgebracht damit das klar ist mit kalter
Krieg ist nicht die Energiewende gemeint
der Golfkrieg wurde nicht
von Tiger Woods angezeigt
Romulus und Remus sind keine Regale von
Ikea das Kapital hat nicht Joe Ackermann
geschrieben er hat entwendet das Buch Genesis
ist nicht die Biografie von Phil Collins
und der 30-jährige Krieg ist nicht die
Jubiläum nach der silbernen Hochzeit [Applaus]